- [Narrator] You might be
familiar with holograms
(soft electronic music)
or three dimensional light projections
from movies like Star Wars.
- I regret that I'm unable
(dramatic music)
to present my father's
request to you in person.
(graphics blip softly)
(graphics whoosh)
- Hi, I'm Tim Draper, I'm.
- [Narrator] Now, they're
(soft electronic music)
popping up in workplaces,
as businesses find ways
to battle Zoom fatigue in
this era of remote working.
Tech executives say this kind of hologram
may soon be common in conference
rooms around the world.
(upbeat electronic music)
- Hey Drew,
can you check out these new designs,
and let me know if you approach?
(graphics blip softly)
(graphics blip)
- I think the pandemic
(soft electronic music)
has accelerated just the need
and use of this technology.
It's a little easier to create
a hologram of yourself, your colleagues.
- [Narrator] Along with beaming
into meetings or events.
(people laugh)
- Man, that's just amazing to me.
- [Narrator] Holograms
(electronic music)
are being used in fields
like healthcare, engineering,
education, gaming, and entertainment.
- And so, we see this being a
stepping stone for people to get creative
about how they teach,
whether it's on the modeling side,
whether it's on the 3D structure side,
chemical engineering,
it's a whole new universe.
- [Narrator] But hologram
technology could have limits
in the workplace.
They also tend to have a
higher price point compared
to other types of
communication technology.
With Zoom fatigue spreading, could this be
the next evolution
(audience claps)
in remote work?
How practical are holograms in the office?
And are they worth the cost?
(graphics click)
- Hi, I'm David Nussbaum.
I'm the founder and CEO of Proto!
(graphics click)
(soft music)
- [Narrator] Proto is a Los
Angeles based tech company
that offers life-sized
photorealistic projections.
- I'm Billy Morrison, I
play guitar for Billy Idol.
- There is 30,000 lumens
of interior light.
So, whatever the content
is, whether it's a 3D model,
or whether it's an NFT, or
whether it's a real person
materializing in before you, it'll appear
like that person is there.
- [Narrator] Proto's holograms
(soft electronic music)
appear on a 7-foot tall booth
or a smaller 24-inch box.
A user can beam in from
anywhere in the world.
They just need a camera, a
plain backdrop, as well as
a set of speakers and
microphones to record them
in real time.
- But we have also just
created an app that allows
the person to use their iPhone.
So in time, when an employee,
or CEO, or anybody needs
to beam into a location,
they don't need to have
an entire studio setup,
all they need is a phone and our free app.
- [Narrator] The hologram market
is projected to
(David speaks distantly)
double in growth from
$2.7 billion in 2020,
to about $5.4 billion in 2024.
This is largely driven by
the technology's wide range
of commercial applications.
- The hologram industry
right now is made up
of both tech giants and smaller startups.
So, companies from the big
tech giants like Google
and Microsoft are involved in the space,
as well as smaller startups.
And they each vary with
what they're offering
to consumers and businesses.
(graphics click)
- [Narrator] Right now,
(soft electronic music)
Proto's hologram system is largely aimed
at business customers.
Clients like Netflix,
T-Mobile, and Formula E racing
have used the device to communicate
between offices, or beam into trade shows,
entertainment events, and seminars.
(man speaks distantly)
(audience claps)
(graphics click)
Proto's larger device
is priced at $60,000,
or it can be rented for
about $25,000 per event.
- We were recently at
New York Fashion Week,
where we were able to
beam in fashion models
from all over the place, into the device.
They have the ability to walk around also
because we can track people.
We're using it for financial institutions,
and interoffice
communication, for telecoms,
for office work.
- [Narrator] Meanwhile, the University
of Central Florida is using
Proto's hologram device
as an education tool.
- Talking and walking, right?
That's something that we
do all the time, and we.
- [Narrator] Medical students can interact
with both live and prerecorded projections
of patients with a variety
of medical conditions.
- It's like telehealth,
but it's a hologram health
because the person is really
standing there before you
with all of her shadows and reflections,
and volumetric effects.
(graphics clicks)
- [Narrator] Other hologram
firms are more focused on the
consumer market,
(graphics blip)
such as San Diego based, Ikin.
Early next year, it plans
to launch a hologram device
that users can clip
into their mobile phone.
The company says it
will be able to project
a transparent 3D hologram
of people on video conferencing calls.
- It's more comfortable to look
at something that's spatially normalized
to your environment.
It's also less intense light.
And we retain the color saturation.
We retain the resolution, the detail,
but we also soften that light energy
to the point where now
it's one more normalized
to the environment, but
it's less harsh to the eyes.
So, you can actually
experience it for longer
without getting fatigue.
- [Narrator] Estimated
to cost less than $500,
Ikin says the device will
allow users to move media
from their phone directly
into the holographic display.
- We refer to it as
interplay between states.
So, you have something on the 2D screen,
you can actually swipe it
up into the environment,
it'll immediately be translated.
And then, you can swipe
it back to the phone,
which is quite cool.
- [Narrator] Ikin's hologram devices
are currently being used
by several businesses,
including a U.S. military contractor,
that is using the technology to help find
and stock inventory in large warehouses.
(graphics click)
Holograms are also being
used to help aid on-the-job
field repair and research.
Microsoft's HoloLens 2 was used to create
a deep sea exploration vessel's
holographic laboratory.
Wearing the headsets allowed scientists
to interact with holographic diagrams,
and collaborate from labs
and offices around the world.
- You have companies using
them to remotely train people
for jobs that require
people to really understand
how a big machine works.
- [Narrator] Still, the often
bulky equipment and costs
associated with holograms,
means they have yet
to prove useful for daily interactions.
- While there are some companies
out there looking to make
these devices more consumer-friendly
and cheaper, right now,
it's still pretty outta
root for most consumers.
So even if a consumer wanted
to use it with their friends
or family, it's a little out
of most people's price range.
- [Narrator] As with any
new form of technology,
hologram experiences
are not always seamless.
The user experience varies
greatly depending on what type
of device is being used.
For instance, some are
more photo realistic,
while others are more cartoony.
Certain holograms can only work
in specific types of
lighting, while others
require access
(EDM music plays distantly)
to a strong power source.
- You can have holograms that
perhaps, don't render as well
in someone's computer because
of something they're using,
or maybe their internet is
just really bad that day.
And they (chuckles)
won't be able to see you
the way you're meant to be seen.
- [Narrator] While hologram companies push
for more widespread adoption,
growing demand is driving
millions of dollars of investments
in the tech and venture capital world.
- You have players like
a tech giant like Google
starting to enter the space as well.
And I think you're starting
to see smaller startups
gain more interest, more
funding, and just actually be
something that we don't
talk about as something
in the movies.
And something that we might
be able to use every day,
or see more often during
events, or in the workplace.
(soft electronic music continues)